PLAYOFFS.
THIS GAME IS UNDER WAY BETWEEN
THE WINNIPEG JETS AND THE HAT
REALLY SET THE TABLE FOR THIS
ANSWERS BACK FOR THE
WINNIPEG JETS!
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ] LITTL
ON SAROS WHO HISTORICALLY IS  PD
WHAT A
TH
THE JETS HAVE TAKEN A ONE-GOAL
LEAD THANKS TO PIERRE-LUC
DUBOIS! SCHMIDT, NOT A
HARD ONE, JUST THE BACKHAND TO E
PREVENTING THISRS HAVE PUT
THEMSELVES WITHIN ONE WITH A
POWERPLAY GOAL! COUSINS ROLLS O
CHECK AND THEN THROWS IT IN THE
NET. UP, TIPPED IN TO
THE NET BY KRISTIANAN LANE.
VESALAINEN'S LEFT WIDE OPEN IN
FRONT.
PO
POINT!
AND THE NASHVILLE PREDATORS ARE
AGAIN WITHIN ONE..REDIRECTS IT,
YOU CAN SEE THE REACTION HERE
FROM HELLEBUYCK..cheering ]
AND FORSBERG GOES AND THERE'S
THE REDIRECT BY STASTNY, AHOT B
LONG AND RIGHTLY SO.
NOW HE PUTS A BOW ON TIMER!
HELLEBUYCK GOT HIS GLOVE ON THAT
TO KEEP IT OUT!SSESSION AND THE
IN AFTER GETTING HIT WITH THE
PUCK TO DIDN'T
THINK SO, BUT FROM THOSE TWO
DEFINITELY TO ME THAT GOAL'S
GOING TO COME BACK.
THE TIME OF 6:25 GOES BACK ON
THE NASHVILLE PREDATORS STILL O.
HE FINDS THE